说话人 1: 哈喽，欢迎来到真实社交，我是Jaxon
说话人 1: 今天还是给大家讲解上次的一个聊天案例，接下来的一个操作
说话人 1: 上次咱们不是讲到有确定感吗
说话人 1: 不一定要现在，只是想有确定感
说话人 1: 她这里给了我一个很大的一个推，就把我整个人给推开了
说话人 1: 因为当时我也在忙事，我也没有管她
说话人 1: 过了 5 天，我又开始跟她打一个招呼，我拍了拍她
说话人 1: 兄弟们，很多时候打一个招呼，我都是坐着去拍
说话人 1: 拍一拍，我没有问，在吗
说话人 1: 今天还好吗
说话人 1: 我懒得去打字，一个拍一拍已经足够了
说话人 1: 真正有窗口的女生，真正会愿意回复你的女生，一个拍一拍已经足够了，不需要去做那些花里胡哨的开场白，用尽各种心机，用尽各种他们的方法，不需要，只需要拍一拍
说话人 1: 我觉得这是微
说话人 1: 信他们的最伟大的一个功能，他后面更新的最伟大的一个功能，我个人觉得啊
说话人 1: 他这里回了一个嗯哼，是一个蛮正向的一个回复，没有很装逼，没有很，很正常，很有窗口的一个回复，嗯哼，意思是你要干嘛
说话人 1: 他也拍了拍我，我回了一个少喝酒，兄弟们可能觉得有点无厘头啊这句话，我给你们说这句话很
说话人 1: 大家看一下这个时间，是已经 10: 30 了
说话人 1: 我那个时候拍他，因为我刚好在外面，我猜他应该在喝酒，我就做了一个试探的窗口，我说少喝酒
说话人 1: 如果说他在喝酒，那么他会回我关你什么事
说话人 1: 或者说有邀约的信号，或者说他真的在喝酒，我可能就会直接去他那
说话人 1: 直接去进行一个约会的一个操作
说话人 1: 而且这句话代表了我们的一个情商非常的高，就这短短的三个字，包含了非常多的信息，有邀约，有冷读，同时还有一个很亲密的一个感觉，你少喝酒，对身体不好
说话人 1: 有这样一个熟悉感，就像真正的很好的朋友一样，很熟的朋友一样的那种感觉
说话人 1: 这句话非常的精髓，然后他回了一
说话人 1: 一句我没喝酒啊
说话人 1: OK，到了这里我就知道今天我是约不了她了，因为时间已经太晚了
说话人 1: 兄弟们看到没有
说话人 1: 这种很没有需求感的一个东西，就可以问出她有没有邀约的窗口，现在可不可以约她
说话人 1: 她是一个什么样的状态
说话人 1: 非常的细节
说话人 1: 这里我发了一句，算我以为，只是我单方面的，可能我们今天会见得到，仅此而已
说话人 1: 咱们马
说话人 1: 上进入主题，改喝咖啡，比如明天
说话人 1: 看到没有
说话人 1: 兄弟们，很顺滑的一个操作，直接就过渡到邀约，因为你没喝酒，咱们改喝咖啡，比如明天，把时间还有做什么事一下就给确定了
说话人 1: 地点已经在前面已经确定好了，所以说咱们不需要确定地点，只要把时间确定好，把邀约确定好就 OK 了
说话人 1: 然后她说我明天忙完跟你说吧
说话人 1: OK，这里我已经知道这个消息了，咱们不必要回她了，脑子里知道有这个消息就行了
说话人 1: 然后到了第二天的一个下午，快接近 3 点的样子，她问你在忙
说话人 1: OK，兄弟们，你们再怎么迟钝，你也知道这个女生她是在约你了
说话人 1: 但是我当时是吃的有点太饱了，准备消化一下，休息一下才准备见她的，所以说我说
说话人 1: 吃晚饭
说话人 1: 饭没多久，这个女生她说我在观音桥的，意思是让你去过去找她
说话人 1: 这里我说，我说你怎么每次都在观音桥
说话人 1: 你住那边吗
说话人 1: 我不太想在观音桥见，因为离我稍微可能半个多小时，我需要去坐车
说话人 1: 她说是的
说话人 1: OK，那我可能四五点的时候，你那个时候可以吗
说话人 1: 我想休息一下再过去见她，因为才吃了饭，很饱很累，想午休一下
说话人 1: 就需要表达出自己的一个需求，表达出自己的一个感受，让这个女人知道你是一个真实的人，而不是一只只会舔的一只小狗
说话人 1: 她说喝咖啡，这个女生她很在乎一个形式上的一个东西，所以咱们需要一直表达自己的一个态度，喝不喝咖啡，喝什么东西，吃什么东西不重要
说话人 1: 她说北方爷们这个声音，因为我口音是有带一点稍微有点北方的那种调，所以说会给她这样的感觉
说话人 1: 这句话她本身是感觉不出什么兴趣指标，感觉不出什么很大的窗口，所以说咱们直接无视掉
说话人 1: 我说第一次见喝咖啡比较合适，这里我在暗示她，我不可能请你吃饭
说话人 1: 不可能请你去做什么很大的消费，不可能带你去什么很好的餐厅，第一次见只是喝咖啡比较合适，甚至于喝咖啡我都只是
说话人 1: 在微信上说喝咖啡，到了真正现实见面，他已经来了，可能摆在他面前的只是一杯白开水，或者说白开水都没有，有可能是那种的一个情况
说话人 1: 到了这里，我说待会见，我先休息一会，上午训练太累了
说话人 1: 他说他也太累了
说话人 1: 这个时候已经到了 3 点多了，他说他也太累了，身上就湿透了，他说改天喝吧
说话人 1: 因为
说话人 1: 我当时也有点累，我也不太想见，我没有去把邀约给他很强硬的一个变现，也表达出我们的一个无需求感，可以放，也可以收
说话人 1: 她这里说，她说而且我最近咖啡喝多了，睡不着
说话人 1: 女的，她他们的，就这个女的，她逻辑很怪啊，她总以为我约她喝咖啡是只能喝咖啡，就很
说话人 1: 但我不想理她这个问题，我直接发了个OK
说话人 1: 又过了大概一周多的样子吧，我又拍了拍她，打了一个招呼
说话人 1: 然后她也很扯淡，她说这样打招呼不礼貌
说话人 1: 我拿这个点反而来嘲讽她，我说数鸽子的女生才不礼貌
说话人 1: 她跟我装傻呀，她说此话怎讲
说话人 1: 我没给她解释这个问题，因为我觉得那个东西不重要，我就直接邀约，我说周末适合出来走走
说话人 1: 这是一个很试探性的一个
说话人 1: 假性的一个邀约，就给他形容一下当时的感觉，比较自然的一个邀约，什么时间，问他什么地方，这种很硬很直接的一个话语，不是那种
说话人 1: 女生她就能懂得起这句话，她说喝咖啡
说话人 1: 到了这里，我忍不住了，我说开水也可以，你自己选，也是表达出咱们的一个无所谓的态度，喝咖啡也好，喝开水也好，喝什么饮料也好，无所谓，主要是人与人之间的见面
说话人 1: 我说重要吗
说话人 1: 就喝什么东西重要吗
说话人 1: 他说说重点，不喜欢没目的的走路
说话人 1: 就这个女人，她还在装，明明我已经很强烈的意图了，就要见她这个人，就对她这个人感兴趣，她还在他们的装，因为她想把你的需求感给她明明白白的表现出来，但我表现出的只有意图，没有需求感
说话人 1: 我给兄弟们讲一下什么叫意图，什么叫需求感
说话人 1: 意图就是你想
说话人 1: 想见这个女人，但是你不一定非要见这个女人，这是意图
说话人 1: 什么叫需求感
说话人 1: 需求感就是你非得见这个女人不可，你很想很想见她，多过她想见你，这就叫需求感
说话人 1: 我直接嘲讽他，我直接打了一个问号
说话人 1: 兄弟们，像不像你发的很装逼的话，女人给你打了一个问号，像不像
说话人 1: 就用其人之道，还治其人之身
说话人 1: 非常的爽啊
说话人 1: 她说听不懂啊
说话人 1: 我给她发了一句，我看起来像男闺蜜吗
说话人 1: 我引用了这句话，我说虽然还算温柔，但我不够了解你
说话人 1: 我的意思是我约你出来喝咖啡也好，喝开水也好，只是因为我需要了解一下你，而不是出来跟你没目的的走路
说话人 1: 我在嘲笑她这一点，非常的啊，这个女人
说话人 1: 她还没懂得上，她说我说问你想
说话人 1: 想做什么
说话人 1: 哈哈哈，哎，这个女的真他们的，我真的当时一瞬间我不知道她的情商是真的很低，还是她装的有那么天真，就在那一瞬间，我是分辨不清楚的
说话人 1: 我发了一个表情，我很无语，我说撩你这件事情已经够明显了吧
说话人 1: 她说，谁这样评价你呀
说话人 1: 男闺蜜那句话，她说谁这样评价你呀
说话人 1: 她还没 get 到我的点
说话人 1: 她说哪里撩我了吗
说话人 1: 把咖啡喝了吧，你在哪
说话人 1: 我说这么快
说话人 1: 因为这个女人她给我一种感觉，跟你出来很礼貌的见面的感觉，所以说我们要把这个东西给它处理掉，不能让她他们的因为礼貌出来见我们，这个很重要
说话人 1: 这个东西它关联到你后面的肢体升级，关联到你后面的定游戏规则，这个
说话人 1: 东西很重要，一定要让她不能因为礼貌而出来见你
说话人 1: 她说不要啰嗦，你不是一直要喝咖啡吗
说话人 1: 不然吃饭聊天
说话人 1: 这个女的，她还在给我上框架，还在跟我装逼
说话人 1: 她说你不是一直要喝咖啡吗
说话人 1: 这很扯淡，明明是她也想见
说话人 1: 我说只是我想见吗
说话人 1: 我就引用了她这句话，嘲笑她这句话很装逼
说话人 1: 她说我
说话人 1: 文字只能表达 20% 的意思，所以聊天要当面聊
说话人 1: OK，从这句话我终于看出他需求感已经出来了，而且不是因为礼貌而跟我们见面，从这一点开始，咱们就要给他复格了，因为他已经达到我们的一个短期的一个要求了
说话人 1: OK，这个时候我们的态度马上就变了，我说我赞同，我是想约你明天下午，今天是跟你敲定时间，是怕你万一又鸽我
说话人 1: 咱们会很仔细的把这件事情，很认真的把这件事情给他应对出来，给他一个关于我们的一个诚意，知道吧
说话人 1: 这就叫社交，必须两方都要有诚意，才能达成一个共识，而不是单方面的一个输出，知道吧
说话人 1: 不管男生还是女生，都不能单方面的一个输出，必须两个人达到一个共识
说话人 1: 他说明天下午我不一定有时间，但是我
说话人 1: 我现在是有空，她还想让咱们去投资
说话人 1: 就这个女人她真的太他们的会定框架了
说话人 1: 兄弟们， 99% 的男人，你们 99% 的男人，扛不到这个点，扛不到这一轮
说话人 1: 这个女的太他们的会装逼了，真的扛不到这一轮，所以你们得小心
说话人 1: 当时不是星期五吗
说话人 1: 我说周天，意思是再隔两天再见
说话人 1: 她说现在你不是空着的吗
说话人 1: OK，这里需求感已经出来了，她说你现在不是空着的吗
说话人 1: 其实是她想见我，她上一句话，我现在是有空，我定了一个周天，她说现在你不是空着的吗
说话人 1: 大家仔细体会一下这句话，是他们的她想见我，只是这个东西她把责任推到你的身上
说话人 1: 我说待会就忙起来了，我说我像装逼的吗
说话人 1: 她说你做什么工作呀
说话人 1: 我只
说话人 1: 怎么知道
说话人 1: 为什么喜欢问别人眼中的自己
说话人 1: 他没有 get 到我的点，我下一句话就给他解释，给他阐明我这句话的一个意思
说话人 1: 他在这里给我说，你就是你，独一无二的
说话人 1: 这里我说，我的意思是我没装逼，忙就是忙，闲就是闲，咱们一定要把感觉给他消灭掉
说话人 1: 他不是在感觉我在装逼吗
说话人 1: 我直接说我为什么这样做，我说我
说话人 1: 没装逼，忙就是忙，闲就是闲，就是在忙，我不是跟你装逼而不出来见你，一定要解决这个点
说话人 1: 她的框架马上就弱下来了，她马上从一个很装逼的女人变成了一个小女生
说话人 1: 她说好的吧，我笨
说话人 1: 这种就像一个女生在认错的一个感觉，所以说咱们可以感觉得到她的框架已经弱下来了，很好的一个信号
说话人 1: 我不想跟她掰扯了，我直接定好时间，我说
说话人 1: 周天下午见
说话人 1: 他说明天你几点忙完嘛
说话人 1: 明天 2 点半我去看个音乐会
说话人 1: 到这里，已经很明显了，是他想见我们，他的需求感已经完全被勾出来了
说话人 1: OK，既然我已经知道你的需求感已经完全被勾出来了，这个时候就由我来充当被你追逐的角色
说话人 1: 我说 4 点后可以
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这种口气像不像他们的正妹对你们说几点后可以见
说话人 1: 是不是像正妹在给你们制定游戏规则
说话人 1: 在给你们制定怎么相处的游戏规则
说话人 1: 似曾相识，对不对
说话人 1: 到了第二天，到了点的时候，我说几点忙完
说话人 1: 她说我在听音乐会，完了跟你说
说话人 1: 兄弟们，在 4 点钟后可以，后面女生没有回了，你的社交直觉只要及格，你就知道女生是已经默认
说话人 1: 答应你这次邀约了，你只需要
说话人 1: 第二天到了那个点去问他就可以了
说话人 1: 你不要到了第二天，你还问他可以吗
说话人 1: 还在那里确定一些邀约，确定什么的东西
说话人 1: 这个直觉你们应该有，所以这里不讲多了
说话人 1: 他音乐会完了，他说你在哪里哪里见
说话人 1: 我打了个大坪问号，因为我离这边比较近，本来最开始是定的观音桥，但实在不想去，所以我
说话人 1: 他不愿意来大坪，咱们再说，再沟
说话人 1: 但一定要把我们的一个需求先讲出来，因为这个位置它离我的家很近，我可以带去收尾也好，或者说我转场也好，都是一个很方便的一个地方
说话人 1: 然后这里他说可以，我马上过来
说话人 1: 然后这里我还是很强硬的一个框架，我说 5 点能到吗
说话人 1: 因为我不喜欢等人，也不喜欢别人迟到，所以说我在这里给他很强的一个框架，很强的一个分寸感
说话人 1: 然后他这里框架已经完全没有了，他说
说话人 1:  20 分钟，已经在路上了
说话人 1: 兄弟们，到了这个点，这个女的，她的框架已经跟最开始，婊里婊气的样子，已经完全不同了
说话人 1: 她从一只老虎，一只母老虎，慢慢的被我给驯化成一只小猫
说话人 1: 本来女人就应该当一只小猫，这样才可爱，对吧
说话人 1: 这是很重要的一个点，框架，聊天很重要的
说话人 1: 一个点框架，我直接给他发了一个位置，他还在问去干嘛呢
说话人 1: 我说坐会，我这个时候懒得跟他掰扯了，因为他已经上车了
说话人 1: 这个东西，只要你不在聊天上下头，到了这个点就已经势不可挡了，我们一定会见面，我不想再跟他扯很多
说话人 1: 你们可以看到我后面有一个操作非常的，完美诠释了什么叫强框架
说话人 1: 这里他说我到了，我说在里面，因为我不是给他发了一个位置吗
说话人 1: 在沃克斯那个咖啡厅里面，就让他直接进来，我说在里面
说话人 1: 他说哪里坐
说话人 1: 他可能没有来过那个店，也有可能觉得我在商场里面，就没有在店里面
说话人 1: 我给他说，我说在店里面啊，不是给你发位置了
说话人 1: 他说我去店里面干嘛
说话人 1: 到了这里我才知道，他可能不知道那是一个店，或者说他没来过
说话人 1: 我说在咖啡厅里面，他说你是一个人吧
说话人 1: 我说肯定啊，我说你不会带女朋友了吧
说话人 1: 在这里咱们要确定一下，如果说他
说话人 1: 带了朋友，咱们马上就溜，不需要在那里等他
说话人 1: 如果说他带了朋友，你这次就没戏，还有可能给他买单，给他朋友买单，这是最下头的一个情况，所以说咱们早点要问清楚这个事
说话人 1: 他说我朋友走了，送他过来的
说话人 1: 我说快进来吧，就让他别墨迹，别在那里扯那些没用的
说话人 1: 他说在走路，我说确实有点难导航，这里开车的话
说话人 1: 他说这个导航我真的，我在星巴克了
说话人 1: 星巴克它是在 Vegas 那个咖啡厅前
说话人 1: 面那里，他需要从那里走到这里，可能大概有 200 米的样子
说话人 1: 他发这句话的意思，他发这三句话的意思，是想让咱们去接他，想让咱们去做一个安全感的一个动作
说话人 1: 但是咱们的框架已经很强了，已经完全把他压制住了，不需要去做那个动作
说话人 1: 千万不要去接女生，因为你们现在还没有什么关系，你们还不是情侣，你们还不是他们的跑友，你们一点关系都没有，你不要去做这样的一个操作
说话人 1: 不要去接她
说话人 1: 我说星巴克没有座位，意思就是让你别在星巴克坐到我这边来
说话人 1: 我说就一直往前走，就看到了沃克斯
说话人 1: 她跟我解释了一下，她说没有，她说我只是到星巴克这里了，我给你发个消息而已
说话人 1: 她在跟我解释，后面发的就到了，这就是一个完整的一个邀约的一个流程
说话人 1: 大家可以看到，从最开始的女生，一个很装逼的一个框架，由我们的操作，由我们的一个框架，由我们的一个真实的一个体验，让她感觉到什么是一个真正的男人，让她完全按照我们的一个引导，按照我们的一个规则来玩这场游戏
说话人 1: 非常细节、非常危险、非常好玩的一些技巧，分享给大家
说话人 1: OK，这是重磅聊天案例第二部分，大家仔细观看